die demografische Zeitbombe einige der
größten Volkswirtschaften der Welt
Italien Deutschland Japan und China
werden immer älter sie verlieren an
Arbeitskräften was katastrophale
wirtschaftliche und soziale Folgen mit
sich zieht wie können die Länder mit dem
demografischen Druck umgehen und wird
dieser Druck das globale Gleichgewicht
der wirtschaftlichen Großmächte in den
kommenden Jahrzehnten verändern
[Musik]
die Demographie regiert die Welt die
genaue Kombination aus jungen und alten
Arbeitnehmern und Rentnern kann die
wirtschaftliche Zukunft eines Landes
bestimmen
jedes Land hat einen demografischen
Sweetspot in dem die Mehrheit ihrer
Bevölkerung im erwerbsfähigen Alter ist
das heißt es wird gleichzeitig
produziert und konsumiert
Demografie ist extrem wichtig desto mehr
Leute in einem Land leben desto größer
ist die Wirtschaft und desto größer die
Wirtschaft desto mehr Einfluss hat das
Land auf der internationalen Bühne
deswegen sind die USA so mächtig während
europäische Länder sich
zusammenschließen müssen um einen
wirksamen globalen Einfluss zu haben
die Weltbevölkerung hat sich im 20
Jahrhundert zweimal verdoppelt was auch
bedeutet dass die Welt mehr Wohlstand
hervorbrachte
im Jahr 1965 gab es etwa 3,3 Milliarden
Menschen auf dem Planeten jetzt nur 50
Jahre später sind es 7,3 Milliarden
dieser Wachstum hatte also
offensichtlich enorme Auswirkungen auf
die Weltwirtschaft
doch die Weltbevölkerung wächst nicht
nur sie altert auch zu Beginn dieses
Jahrzehnts lag das Durchschnittsalter
der Menschen bei 32 Jahren am Ende
dieses Jahrhunderts werden es 42 Jahre
sein
2035 werden rund 1,1 Milliarden Menschen
über 65 Jahre alt sein diese Alterung
unseres Planeten hat das Potenzial zu
tiefgreifenden wirtschaftlichen
Auswirkungen
dieses agrauen des Planeten hat
potenziell tiefgreifende wirtschaftliche
Auswirkungen wenn die Bevölkerung altert
bedeutet dies dass mehr Menschen Waren
und Dienstleistungen konsumieren und
weniger Menschen sie produzieren und
insgesamt bedeutet das dass eine
Wirtschaft mit einer alternden
Bevölkerung langsamer wachsen wird als
sie es sonst tun würde die Menschen
werden weniger sparen Sie werden mehr
ausgeben und das wird die Zinsen in den
nächsten Jahrzehnten möglicherweise
erheblich in die Höhe treiben und wenn
man sich die Analyse des ehemaligen
Ökonomen der Bank auf England Charlie
Bean ansieht sieht man das laut
Berechnungen genau jetzt das
demografische Alter in die Höhe schießt
wir stehen kurz vor dem Wendepunkt an
dem die Demografie beginnt die Zinsen zu
erhöhen anstatt sie zu drücken viele der
Länder mit dem schnellsten Wachstum
einer Bevölkerung im erwerbsfähigen
Alter liegen in Afrika oder Südostasien
diese Länder stehen kurz vor dem
Eintritt in ein demografisches Fenster
dass das Wirtschaftswachstum sehr
unterstützen wird Indien befindet sich
im frühen Teil eines demografischen
Suizids in dem die Mehrheit seiner
Bevölkerung jetzt im erwerbsfähigen
Alter ist
dies führt dazu dass das Wachstum in
Indien im Jahr 2016 wohl die
voraussichtlich am schnellsten wachsende
Wirtschaft der Welt sein wird wie die
demografischen Faktoren sind ein großer
Rückenwind für dieses Wachstum
für weiterentwickelte Volkswirtschaften
sind die demografischen Verhältnisse
jedoch komplexer und besorgniserregender
für einige Volkswirtschaften
insbesondere in Europa die extrem
verschuldet sind bedeutet das
verlangsamte Wachstum der Arbeitskräfte
oder das Schrumpfen der Arbeitskräfte
dass die Schulden immer weniger
nachhaltig werden es erhöht also
tatsächlich den Druck den diese
Volkswirtschaften ausgesetzt sind
insbesondere Italien oder Deutschland
sind diesen demografischen Problemen
ausgesetzt besonders Deutschland wird
mit dem demografischen Wandel zu kämpfen
haben
diese demografischen Trends wirken
schleichend und weniger sichtbar haben
aber sehr viel Einfluss auf die
Entscheidungen unserer Regierungen
ich denke das Entscheidungen getroffen
werden müssen
akzeptieren wir die Tatsache dass wir
eine alternde Demografie haben wird das
unser Wachstum hemmen oder akzeptieren
wir die Tatsache dass wir Einwanderer
aufnehmen müssen die dann die älteren
Arbeiter ersetzt und somit die alternde
Demografie abfedert
aber auf der anderen Seite müssen sich
Länder fragen wie viele Einwanderer sie
in das Land lassen ohne einen
kulturellen Wandel zu verursachen und
das Leben dort zu verändern
die demografische Tendenz stellt auch
für die Arbeitnehmer ein großes Problem
dar
als populations die demografische
Entwicklung stellt die Arbeitnehmer vor
ähnlich dramatische Probleme
die Bevölkerung altert da wir heutzutage
länger und gesünder leben
es ist also wichtig zu verstehen dass
wenn wir den materialistischen Wohlstand
der letzten Jahrzehnte in der Zukunft
beibehalten möchten werden Menschen auch
länger arbeiten müssen
ein Experte für internationale Politik
seiner Meinung nach deuten die
derzeitigen bevölkerungstrends auf eine
ganz andere Welt hin eine Welt in der
selbst mächtige Volkswirtschaften wie
Japan und China vor katastrophalen
demografischen Herausforderungen stehen
wir werden im Laufe des Jahrhunderts
eine große demografische Veränderungen
und ein Bevölkerungswachstum sehen
wir werden nicht in Verzweifelung
zergehen aber ich denke wir könnten
durchaus in eine Ära der Frustration
geraten ausgelöst durch enormen
demografischen Drogen
die demografische Entwicklung verändert
unsere Welt für Steven chen bietet sie
einen einzigartigen Einblick in die
globale Wirtschaft und Politik Professor
chen hat in Nordamerika Europa Afrika
und Asien gelehrt und war als Diplomat
und Berater für das britische und das
US-Außenministerium tätig ihn fasziniert
die Frage wie Demographie internationale
Angelegenheiten beeinflusst auch aus
persönlichen Gründen
meine Eltern waren Flüchtlinge während
des Zweiten Weltkrieges irgendwie fanden
sie ihren Weg nach Neuseeland der
Schiffskapitän meinte zu ihnen dass es
besser wäre wenn sie dort aussteigen
südlich von dort gibt es nur Pinguine
das Menschen migrieren müssen und damit
um die Welt reisen wertschätze ich wegen
meiner Familiengeschichte sehr was ich
überraschend finde ist dass Menschen
glauben in einer Welt ohne
demografischen Wandel zu leben zu können
in unserer globalisierten Welt ist die
Demografie wichtig in einigen Ländern
gibt es zu viele Menschen was zu
internem Druck und Migration führt
andere haben zu wenig das führt zu einer
schrumpfenden Bevölkerung im
erwerbsfähigen Alter
es wird enorme demografische
Veränderungen geben immer mehr Probleme
durch das alternde Bevölkerung und
natürlich dadurch ein Überfließen von
Bevölkerungen von verschiedenen Ländern
die
flüchtlingskrisen sind ein modernes
Beispiel es gibt sie ihr sehr große
Bedenken wegen der alternden
Arbeitskräfte
nicht genug junge Menschen schließen
sich der Wirtschaft in einer produktiven
Art und Weise an und nicht genug junge
Menschen bekommen die notwendige
Ausbildung um einen wichtigen Beitrag zu
Wirtschaft leisten zu können
[Musik]
das bevölkerungsreichste Land der Welt
china hatte in den letzten 50 Jahren
nach mau mit demografischen Krisen zu
kämpfen sind die Regierung des Landes
hat unterschiedliche Strategien
angewandt um mit den demografischen
Trends umzugehen
großer Technokrat oder Planer er hatte
oft plötzliche Stimmungsschwankungen er
war sehr traditionell und wusste die
chinesischen Impulse seiner Anhänger zu
nutzen um seine Macht in der Bevölkerung
zu stärken
aber das war bisher auch nie profitabel
über einen gewissen Punkt
hinauszuwachsen da es in den frühen
Jahren der kommunistischen Revolution zu
nahrungsen und zu einer landesweiten
Hungersnot geführt hatte
Menschen man hat desto mehr muss der
Staat für die Menschen darin sorgen es
ist also eine Belastung für den Staat zu
viele Menschen zu haben deshalb hat
China beschlossen die Politik des
Bevölkerungswachstums zu bedenken die
natürlich ins andere Extrem gegangen ist
und versucht hat das
Bevölkerungswachstum zu begrenzen
die ein Kind Politik machte Maus Pläne
zunichte mit katastrophalen Folgen
Chinas Fruchtbarkeitsrate also die Zahl
der Geburten pro Frau sang stark Anfang
der 70er Jahre lag sie noch bei 5,9
heute ist sie auf unter 1,6 gesunken
Demographen schätzen dass ein Land eine
Fruchtbarkeitsrate von 2,1 braucht um
eine stabile Bevölkerung zu erhalten
china steht nun am Rande eines
demografischen Abgrunds mit enormen
sozialen Folgen
ich denke wenn wir uns China heute
ansehen dann sehen wir eine Führung die
erkannt hat dass die Fortsetzung der ein
Kind Politik nur zu langfristigen
Schwierigkeiten führen wird
insbesondere wenn man eine alternde
Bevölkerung hat die niemanden hat der
sich um sie kümmert wenn es immer nur
ein Kind gibt und nicht sozusagen eine
Masse von Kinder oder zum Beispiel keine
Großfamilie mit vielen Kindern mehr hat
die sich die älteren kümmern können und
dann wird diese alternde Bevölkerung zu
einer Belastung für die Bestrebungen der
jüngeren
diese Probleme werden erst jetzt
deutlich in China ist die Bevölkerung im
erwerbsfähigen Alter seit 2012
rückläufig
die zweitgrößte Volkswirtschaft der Welt
verliert immer mehr Arbeitskräfte im
Jahr 2025 wird es 316 Millionen Chinesen
über 60 Jahre geben das entspricht fast
der gesamten heutigen Bevölkerung der
Vereinigten Staaten im Jahr 2015 gab
China die ein Kind Politik auf China
ich denke China blickt sehr besorgt in
die mittelfristige Zukunft es könnte bis
zu 20 Jahre dauern bis diese Kinder
erwachsen sind ungeschult werden und an
einer wettbewerbsfähigeren Arbeitswelt
teilnehmen können
solange das nicht der Fall ist wird es
einen Engpass geben nicht nur in Bezug
auf die Investitionen in die Ausbildung
dieser jungen Menschen sondern auch in
Bezug auf die Frage ob der Staat die
älteren Menschen unterstützen kann die
in den Ruhestand gehen bevor die jüngere
Generation die wirtschaftliche
Leistungsfähigkeit erreicht hat um sich
um sie zu kümmern
Steven glaubt dass die demografische
Entwicklung Chinas kein fataler Fehler
sein muss es könnte das Wachstum für
einige Zeit bremsen
die chinesische Wirtschaft wächst
weiterhin vielleicht nicht mehr so stark
aber sie muss weiter wachsen damit sie
den Menschen weiterhin Beschäftigung
bieten kann
was die Auswirkungen Chinas auf den Rest
der Welt betrifft so haben die Chinesen
genügend Devisen um weiterhin unsere
Produkte zu kaufen ich glaube nicht dass
China ein Problem hat es werden
sicherlich auch weiterhin chinesische
Produkte gekauft in China hergestellte
Kleidung ist in jeder europäischen
Einkaufsstraße vertreten
die chinesische Regierung rechnet nun
damit dass die Bevölkerung des Landes im
Jahr 2020 ihren Höchststand erreichen
wird bevor sie zu schrumpfen beginnt in
Japan hatte der Rückgang bereits
zwischen 2010 und 2015 begonnen die
Bevölkerung des Landes schrumpfte bis
zum Ende dieses Jahrhunderts um
947.345 Menschen bei denen erwarten dass
die Bevölkerung des ist von
127,1 Millionen auf nur noch 83
Millionen sinken wird anderen
schätzungen zufolge könnte sich die
Bevölkerung auf 52 Millionen mehr als
halbieren
kulturelle Aspekte verstärken diesen
Trend zusätzlich
Japan hat eine ganze Reihe an dem
grafischen Problemen ganze Ballungsräume
haben mit demografischen Problemen zu
kämpfen sie haben außerdem mit
Verschiebungen und mit einer alternden
Bevölkerung zu tun
sicherlich haben Sie auch viel mit
sozialen Trends und Gewohnheiten zu tun
die Regierung in Japan möglichst
ignorieren will die Kultur des hohen
Alters in Japan verwehrt jüngeren
Arbeitnehmern die Flexibilität die sehr
strengen sozialen gepflogen hätten die
die volle Beteiligung von Frauen am
Erwerbsleben verhindern schränken die
Flexibilität noch weiter ein strenge
Vorschriften darüber wann man mit dem
rentenbezirk beginnen kann führen dazu
dass die Menschen in einer Arbeit
feststecken die sie nicht mehr machen
wollen sie wurde nicht lernen neue Wege
zu gehen und sie werden am Arbeitsplatz
genauso zum Zug wie sie es für den Staat
wären wenn sie aus dem Berufsleben
ausscheiden und in den Ruhestand gehen
würden
Japan hat sich bisher gegen die jüngsten
demografischen Trends gesträubt und
vermietet sich mit dem Problem aber auch
mit der Lösung zu befassen der Migration
ich denke eines unserer Probleme ist
dass wir immer dachten die
Globalisierung würde nach unseren
Bedingungen ablaufen aber jetzt gibt es
eine vielschichtige Globalisierung wo es
Druck von vielen globalen Akteuren in
verschiedenen Teilen der Welt gibt ich
glaube nicht dass wir jetzt in der Lage
sein werden den Geist wieder in die
Flasche zurückzustecken wenn es um
größere Migrationen aus dem Nahen Osten
oder Nordafrika nach Europa geht das ist
ein Phänomen dass uns meiner Meinung
nach auf die eine oder andere Weise
erhalten bleibt die Zahlen werden
steigen die Zahl die jeder die aus
diesen Teilen der Welt nach Europa
kommen wird steigen tschüss
mehrere EU-Länder haben ihre eigenen
demografischen Probleme die deutsche
Regierung rechnet damit dass im Jahr
2016 ein Drittel der Bevölkerung über 65
Jahre alt sein wird
Europas größte Volkswirtschaft muss mehr
Arbeitskräfte finden und diejenigen die
bereits arbeiten sollten sich darauf
einstellen länger zu arbeiten und später
in Rente zu gehen
die Extensions die Verlängerung der
Lebensarbeitszeit wird immer einer der
großen politischen Knackpunkte sein aber
das geht nicht nur darum die Menschen
dazu zu bringen in Beschäftigung zu
bleiben es muss eine bestimmte Art von
Beschäftigung sein wie kann man die Art
von Arbeitsplätze schaffen die den
Menschen nicht nur Arbeit geben sondern
sie auch in einer hochproduktiven Weise
eines 21 jahrhunderts beschäftigen
drei der vier größten Volkswirtschaften
der Welt China Japan und Deutschland
stehen vor großen demografischen
Herausforderungen die Entscheidungen die
sie treffen in Bezug auf der Erhöhung
der Geburtenrate die in kaufname von
Abwanderung oder die Verzögerung des
Renteneintritts ihrer Arbeitnehmer
werden darüber entscheiden ob sie in den
kommenden Jahrzehnten noch zu den
mächtigen Nationen der Welt gehören
werden
die demografische Entwicklung ist in
Europa spürbar
die größte Volkswirtschaft des
Kontinents steckt in einer
bevölkerungskrise Deutschland hat die
meisten über 60-Jährigen in der EU die
Wirtschaft leidet in einigen Bereichen
bereits unter einem Fachkräftemangel und
der Automobilhersteller daimler hat über
100 pensionierte Arbeitnehmer wie Emil
Knie wieder eingestellt um die Lücken zu
filmen
also für mich ist ganz persönlicher
benefit als ausscheidender Mitarbeiter
noch gebraucht zu werden zum einen und
dann so viel Respekt und dann auch so
viel Anerkennung zu bekommen in dem
Alter das ist für mich die größte
Herausforderung gewesen und natürlich
auch für mich jetzt das schönste was mir
momentan passieren konnte
das Programm setzt auf ältere
Arbeitnehmer die über wertvolle
Fähigkeiten verfügen also wir haben hier
[Musik]
ältere Mitarbeiter auch beschäftigt aber
es kommt hier nicht nur aufs alte an
sondern es kommt aufs Know-how an und
wichtig ist uns das auch die ältere
Mitarbeiter ihre
langjährige Erfahrung wo sie jetzt
gesammelt haben auch an die jüngere
weitergeben
[Musik]
daimler hat seine Produktionslinien so
modifiziert dass ältere Mitarbeiter mit
ihnen besser zurechtkommen
sie sehen hier im Hintergrund den
überkopfstuhl der überkopfstuhl hat den
Vorteil gegenüber den alten Stationen
dass man im Sitzen eine überkopf
Tätigkeit durchführen kann und hier den
Vorteil hat während der Arbeitszeit zum
einen zu sitzen und zum anderen
ergonomisch viel besser an das Fahrzeug
reinkommt wie im Stehen also wir führen
hier nicht nur Ergonomie Maßnahmen durch
um die ältere zu entlasten sondern wir
wollen alle Mitarbeiter entlasten
natürlich kommt es denn eine älteren
mehr entgegen wie den jüngeren
Mitarbeiter aber sie wissen ja jeder
wird einmal älter und damit ist jeder
irgendwann einmal in der Situation dass
er die Vorteile gerne genießen bis 2024
wird die Hälfte der Mitarbeiter über 50
Jahre alt sein du stehst dass wir die
Hilfe gekriegt haben sie viel angenehmer
zu arbeiten durch das dass die Karosse
nach oben geht und wir kennen müssen
sich nicht und der sich viel viel
angenehmer zu arbeiten ich bin sehr
zufrieden von dem weil er jetzt mit der
Jahre das hängt von dem ab das muss man
sich ziemlich
herunterbiegen und das ist schon nicht
mehr so wie damals war wenn man jünger
war nicht
während sich deutsche Unternehmen auf
ältere Arbeitskräfte vorbereiten bietet
in anderen europäischen Ländern vor
allem die Zuwanderung eine gute
Möglichkeit die demografische Zeitbombe
zu entschärfen hier in satriano Italien
befinden wir uns im Zentrum der
demografischen Krise in Europa
in den 60er Jahren lebten hier glaube
ich über 4000 Menschen heute sind es
noch so ungefähr um die 1.000 Einwohner
die
älteren werden von den Jüngeren einfach
zurückgelassen es sind sehr viele ins
Ausland gegangen um dort Arbeit zu
finden das ist der jetzige Zustand
die Geburtenrate in Italien ist seit 50
Jahren rückläufig und hat den
niedrigsten Stand seit der
Wiedervereinigung im Jahr 1861 erreicht
die italienische Regierung finanziert
nun Dörfer wie es Adriano um Migranten
aus aller Welt aufzunehmen die Hoffnung
ist dass dadurch Italiens demografischer
Niedergang verhindert werden kann
die Anwesenheit dieser Flüchtlinge
stellt unter diesen Gesichtspunkt für
uns eine Wende da sie sind für uns die
Zukunft wir brauchen junge Arbeitskräfte
die sich hier niederlassen und eine
Familie gründen wollen
der Weg den viele Migranten wie Adnan
gemacht haben steht sinnbildlich für den
demografischen Wandel der Welt
ich komme aus Pakistan bevor ich nach
Italien kam habe ich fast zwei Jahre in
Dubai gelebt
danach bin ich dann in den Libanon
gegangen da war ich ungefähr drei Monate
dann bin ich hier nach Italien gekommen
ich bin jetzt fast seit drei Jahren hier
meinen ersten Job hatte ich nach drei
Monaten bei einem Friseur namens
compagnia lavoro
jetzt habe ich hier als Frisör eine gute
Arbeit gefunden die Menschen hier sind
gut zu mir und freundlich es ist eine
gute Arbeit
[Musik]
bei ihrer Ankunft gab es natürlich erst
einmal ein paar Vorurteile das ist ganz
normal aber sie begannen sich sehr
schnell einzuleben und Kontakte zu
knüpfen die nötige Integration nimmt
allmählich Fahrt auf sie findet bei uns
größtenteils auf der Straße oder in
Kaffee statt wo die Leute sich treffen
und wir versuchen das so weit es geht zu
unterstützen
es ist noch zu früh um zu sagen ob diese
Art der gesteuerten Migration die
demografischen Probleme Italiens lösen
werden aber sie hat satriano wieder zu
einem lebendigen Ort gemacht dies
zeichnet auch der demografischen Trend
der vergangenen Jahre ab
ich heiße diese Menschen sehr willkommen
Italiener sind ja ebenfalls vor langer
Zeit nach Argentinien ausgewandert
dort wurden sie ja auch durch niemanden
vertrieben ich weiß nicht warum Italien
diese Menschen nicht aufnehmen sollte
vielleicht kommen irgendwann die
Auswanderer zurück aber dann werden hier
alle bereits wie Brüder zusammen leben
demografische Veränderungen finden
ständig in allen Ländern der Welt statt
der Schlüssel zum zukünftigen Wohlstand
eines Landes liegt darin sie rechtzeitig
zu erkennen
man kann es glaube ich ganz gut anhand
von Produktion und konsumzusammenfassen
eine Wirtschaft produziert und sie
konsumiert auch wenn es zu viele
Menschen eines bestimmten Alters gibt
die aus der Erwerbstätigkeit Ausscheiden
gibt es plötzlich mehr Menschen
innerhalb einer Wirtschaft die
konsumieren aber nicht produzieren das
macht es für ein Land sehr viel
schwieriger zu wachsen
[Musik]
Nachfolger die nicht langfristig
demografisch kluge Politik betreiben
werden mit schweren Folgen konfrontiert
werden und sich großen Herausforderungen
gegenüber sehen Länder die eine
Demografie offene Politik verfolgen und
Veränderungen zulassen werden in Zukunft
erfolgreicher als andere sein
unsere Welt ist geprägt durch Spaltung
und Ungleichheit
in einer wettbewerbsorientierten
Wirtschaft wird es immer eine gewisse
Ungleichheit geben es wird immer
Menschen geben die erfolgreicher als
andere sind das ist nicht das Problem
sondern das Ausmaß
nur etwa ein Prozent der Superreichen
besitzt mehr als die Hälfte des
weltweiten Vermögens
die 62 reichsten Menschen verfügen über
das gleiche Vermögen wie 50% der
Weltbevölkerung das ist in der Tat eine
sehr aufschlussreiche Statistik
wenn wir uns die Gehälter von
Vorstandsvorsitzenden ansehen so sind
diese vom 50-fachen des
durchschnittlichen Arbeiters vor 30
Jahren auf das 300-fache gestiegen das
ist nicht nur ein Problem für die
Investoren sondern auch für die
Arbeitnehmer
Ungleichheit ist eines der wichtigsten
wirtschaftlichen Themen des 21
jahrhunderts aber die Sorge um
Ungleichheit ist keinesfalls neu
[Musik]
wenn wir weit in die Geschichte der USA
zurückblicken sehen wir eine dramatische
Einkommensungleichheit wie zum Beispiel
in den 80er und 90er Jahren des 19
Jahrhunderts bis eine Reihe von
Präsidenten und Regierungen Maßnahmen
ergriffen um die Verhältnisse
auszugleichen es wurden Arbeitsgesetze
erlassen und Steuergesetze geändert
diese Politik setzte sich während des
Zweiten Weltkriegs und bis in die
1960er-Jahren wurden die Steuergesetze
aufgrund der wirtschaftlichen Situation
erneut geändert von den frühen 80ern bis
heute hat die Einkommensungleichheit
daher zugenommen das ist bezeichnend da
die Einkommensungleichheit letztlich zur
vermögensungleichheit beiträgt
mit dem Reichtum kommt auch die Macht in
der Politik in der Unternehmensführung
und in vielen anderen Bereichen der
Wirtschaft wenn also ein großer Teil in
einer Volkswirtschaft oder in einem Land
in den Händen weniger Personen liegt
dann haben diese Personen in der Regel
einen übergroßen Einfluss auf die
wirtschaftliche und politische
Entscheidungsfindung und sind daher in
der Lage Maßnahmen zu ergreifen die
ihren Reichtum noch weiter vergrößern
[Musik]
geht es um mehr als nur Gerechtigkeit
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler befürchten
dass ein extremes Maß an Ungleichheit
dramatische Auswirkungen haben kann
tatsächlich wird es sich auf das Tempo
des weltwirtschaftswachstums aus
ein Beispiel wenn die reichsten mehr
Geld haben geben sie tendenziell weniger
aus auf diese Weise kommt es zu weniger
Konsum und folglich zu weniger
Wirtschaftswachstum
doch das ist nicht die einzige Folge
eine weitere ist das Familien mit
niedrigem und mittlerem Einkommen dazu
neigen mehr Kredite aufzunehmen um ihren
Haushalt zu finanzieren und das schafft
natürlich Risiken
ein dramatisches Ausmaß dieser
Ungleichheit ist gerade in
Entwicklungsländern zu beobachten hier
scheint die Ungleichheit eine
zersetzende Wirkung auf die gesamte
Wirtschaft zu haben
ein weiterer Aspekt den wir in den
Schwellenländern beobachten konnten ist
die Korrelation zwischen Ungleichheit
und Korruption wenn die Regierung nicht
unbedingt für die nötige Bildung und die
Regeln sorgt um allen den Erfolg zu
ermöglichen wenn man sich den arabischen
Frühling in Nordafrika und im Nahen
Osten anschaut dann war eine der
Hauptursachen die mangelnden
wirtschaftlichen Möglichkeiten
wenn sich also durch ein Mangel an
wirtschaftlichen Möglichkeiten eine
extreme Ungleichheit bildet könnte es zu
politischen Unruhen kommen
wenn man ganz oben steht kann sich der
Glaube die Ungleichheit betreffer einen
nicht als gefährlicher Irrtum
herausstellen
[Musik]
es ist klar dass Ungleichheit gerade für
die Menschen am unteren Ende sehr
schlecht ist vor allem dann wenn das
untere Ende auch noch sehr schmal ist
für die Leute an der Spitze wirkt es
also immer ein gewisses Risiko extreme
Ungleichheit kann zu politischen Unruhen
führen zu neuen Regeln zu neuen Steuern
man sollte also sehr zufrieden sein wenn
man zu den oberen der
wirtschaftspyramide gehört auch wenn es
nur kurzfristig ist denn langfristig
sehe ich eher das Potenzial für
Veränderungen die die stabilisierend
wirken können
man muss hier das große und ganze
betrachten an das gesamte
Wirtschaftswachstum und an künftige
Generationen denken denn es hat ja
bewiesenermaßen Auswirkungen auf das
gesamte Wirtschaftswachstum der Welt es
ist also ein Problem dass uns alle
angeht
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler sind
überzeugt dass die Ungleichheit das
Leben der Menschen selbst in den
reichsten Teilen der Welt dramatisch
beeinträchtigt und dass wir dieses
Problem nicht länger ignorieren können
wenn wir Wachstum und sozialen
Zusammenhalt maximieren wollen bei einer
absoluten Einkommensungleichheit müssen
wir meiner Meinung nach eine echte
Debatte führen es gibt eindeutige
Auswirkungen sei es in den Bereichen
Bildung Zugang Gesundheitsversorgung
aber auch in Bezug auf politischer
Herausforderungen und die
Lebenserwartung es ist bewiesen dass
Einkommensungleichheit die treibende
Kraft für einige dieser Faktoren ist
[Musik]
die Ungleichheit ist eines der meist
diskutierten Themen in der Wirtschaft ob
in New York oder Nairobi dann Bisam Mojo
ist eine wirtschaftsexpertin die
aufgrund ihrer Arbeit für Weltbank und
Wall Street zu einer der
einflussreichsten Wirtschaftsexperten
der Welt gehört sie befasst sich mit den
Trends der heutigen Wirtschaft von der
Entwicklungspolitik in Afrika bis hin zu
Rohstoffpreisen in China auch sie
befasst sich mit dem Thema der
Ungleichheit
ist besonders problematisch da sie in
vielen Gesellschaften ein entscheidender
Faktor dafür ist wohin sich der
Lebensstandard der Gesellschaft
entwickelt Daten haben gezeigt dass die
Ungleichheit in den letzten Jahrzehnten
stark zugenommen hat
in den letzten 30 Jahren hat sie sich
sogar an den Vereinigten Staaten im
Vereinigten Königreich und in weiten
Teilen Europas vergrößert ebenso haben
wir festgestellt dass das
Durchschnittseinkommen der obersten ein
Prozent in den Vereinigten Staaten heute
30 Mal so hoch ist wie das
Durchschnittseinkommen der übrigen
Bevölkerung und der übrigen 99%
vergleichen Sie dies mit der Situation
vor 30 Jahren also 1978 dann war das
Einkommen der obersten ein Prozent nur
10 mal größer
[Musik]
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler befürchten
dass die Ungleichheit eine Reihe
sozialer Probleme hervorruft jüngste
Studien in Mexiko deuten darauf hin dass
in Stadtvierteln mit hoher Ungleichheit
mehr Gewaltverbrechen begangen werden
als in solchen in denen die Ungleichheit
weniger ausgeprägt ist
Forscher in anderen Ländern sind so
ähnlichen Ergebnissen gekommen ein
Problem bei der Einkommensungleichheit
sind die Folgen und Auswirkungen die sie
auf eine Gesellschaft hat die Frage ist
ob es möglich ist wie beispielsweise in
den Vereinigten Staaten dass Menschen
mit unterschiedlichem Einkommen und ohne
Aussicht auf eine Verbesserung Seite an
Seite leben können die Bronze ist der
Ärmste Bezirk der Vereinigten Staaten
aber sie ist auch nur 20 Minuten also
etwa fünf Haltestellen mit dem Zug von
einem der reichsten Gegenden der Welt
entfernt der aber ist Zeit von Manhattan
es stellt sich die Frage ob dieses
nebeneinander leben angesichts der
Kriminalitätsrate auf Dauer tragbar ist
auch die Verarmung hat Auswirkungen auf
die Ungleichheit wie etwa im
Gesundheits- oder Bildungswesen und
natürlich auf die politische
Ungleichheit in den Vereinigten Staaten
sind rund 158 Familien für etwa 50% der
Wahlkampffinanzierung im us-wahlsystem
verantwortlich auf Camping das wirft die
Frage auf wo bleibt hier die Demokratie
und wie wirkt sich das auf die
politischen und demokratischen Prozesse
aussehen
die Amerikaner waren schon immer stolz
auf die Möglichkeit des sozialen
Aufstiegs auf die Möglichkeiten
unabhängig von den Umständen in die sie
hineingeboren wurden voranzukommen
jüngste Anzeichen deuten jedoch darauf
hin dass sich dies ändert
es gibt einen grundlegenden Aspekt bei
der Bewältigung des Problems der
Einkommensungleichheit und das ist
meiner Meinung nach die soziale
Mobilität bei der sozialen Mobilität
geht es tatsächlich um die Überzeugung
der Menschen und um den Zugang und die
Möglichkeit der Menschen ihren
Lebensstandard und ihren Lebensunterhalt
über einen bestimmten Zeitraum hinweg zu
verbessern ich glaube dass die Ursache
für die Einkommensungleichheit
insbesondere in den westlichen
Gesellschaften der Zusammenbruch der
sozialen Mobilität ist
um Ihnen einen Eindruck davon zu
vermitteln wenn Sie heute in den
Vereinigten Staaten in die untersten
zwanzig Prozent des Einkommensniveaus
hineingeboren werden haben sie wenn sie
keinen Hochschulabschluss besitzen nur
eine 5-prozentige Chance im Laufe ihres
Lebens zu den oberen 20% zu gehören das
deutet eindeutig darauf hin dass sich
die Einkommensungleichheit vergrößert
und auch ein sozialer Aufstieg wird
behindert ein extremes Maß an
Einkommensungleichheit kann das Wachstum
ganzer Volkswirtschaften beeinträchtigen
die OECD schätzt dass dies den
Industrieländern in einem gewissen
Zeitraum etwa achteinhalb Prozent des
Bruttoinlandproduktes kostet anders
gesagt aufgrund der
Einkommensungleichheit und der sich
ausweitenden Kluft zwischen Arm und
Reich hat sich das bildwachstum in den
letzten 25 Jahren um etwa 8,5%
verlangsamt
heute gibt es echte Bedenken darüber wie
sich das auf längere Sicht und in
Zukunft auswirken könnte viele prognosen
zeigen dass sich das Wirtschaftswachstum
verlangsamen wird und die Auswirkung der
Einkommensungleichheit werden
wahrscheinlich noch stärker ausfallen
[Musik]
das bedeutet dass die Ungleichheit nicht
nur ein Problem für die Menschen am
unteren Ende der wirtschaftlichen Skala
ist
chronische Einkommensungleichheit kann
sich durchaus auf die soziale und
wirtschaftliche Gesundheit aller
auswirken
[Musik]
wenn sie wohlhabend sind und in der
Stadt leben hat die Tatsache dass sie
jeden Tag mit Menschen zu tun haben die
ein niedrigeres Einkommensniveau und
wenig Aussichten haben ihren
Lebensunterhalt zu verbessern eine
absolute und direkte Auswirkung auf ihre
Sicherheit und ihren eigenen
Lebensstandard natürlich in dem Maße
dass die Gesellschaft als Ganzes
wahrscheinlich nicht wachsen wird
meiner Meinung nach ist es wichtig dass
wir dringend dafür sorgen dass sich der
Lebensstandard aller Bürgerinnen und
Bürger insbesondere der Menschen in den
unteren Einkommensschichten über einen
längeren Zeitraum hinweg verbessert
[Musik]
dann bisher glaubt dass der Schlüssel
zur Bekämpfung der Ungleichheit in der
Reaktivierung der sozialen Mobilität
liegt doch dazu müssen zunächst die
Grundbedürfnisse der Bürger in Bezug auf
Gesundheit und Bildung stabilisiert
werden
die wirklichen Herausforderungen die der
Einkommensungleichheit zugrunde liegen
sind meiner Meinung nach mit der Idee
der sozialen Mobilität und den damit
verbundenen Herausforderungen verknüpft
soziale Mobilität braucht jedoch ein
Wirtschaftswachstum ohne Wachstum wird
die Ungleichheit weiter zunehmen
wir müssen ein jährliches bipwachstum
von mindestens 7 Prozent anstreben um
das Pro kopfeinkommen innerhalb einer
Generation zu verdoppeln wir sind weit
von diesem Ziel entfernt
wir haben also reale Probleme mit den
langfristigen Aussichten für das
Wirtschaftswachstum aber auch mit
sozialer Mobilität und mit Möglichkeiten
die Einkommensungleichheit zu verringern
wenn das Problem der Ungleichheit für
den Westen schon besorgniserregend ist
dann verschärft es sich noch in Ländern
mit einer schnellwachsenden jungen
Bevölkerung wenn diese Volkswirtschaft
eine Chance haben sollen die
Ungleichheit zu bekämpfen müssen sich
schnell Millionen von Arbeitsplätzen
schaffen
beyond natürlich ist nicht nur in den
Industrieländern die Sorge groß dass die
Einkommensungleichheit zunimmt sondern
insbesondere in den schnell wachsenden
Schwellenländern wie Brasilien Indien
und Südafrika heute sind etwa 85
Millionen junge Menschen vor allem in
den Schwellenländern im Alter zwischen
18 und 25 Jahren arbeitslos wenn wir
also versuchen wollen das Problem der
Einkommensungleichheit zu beheben müssen
wir dafür sorgen dass wir Wachstum aber
auch wachsende Einkommen haben
zusätzlich müssen wir dafür sorgen dass
die Menschen einen besseren Zugang zu
Bildung und Gesundheitsversorgung haben
damit sie über eine soziale
Infrastruktur verfügen und somit die
soziale Mobilität gefördert wird ohne
diese Faktoren besteht die Gefahr dass
sich der Lebensstandard nicht nur für
den verarmten Teil der Bevölkerung
sondern für die Gesellschaft insgesamt
verschlechtert
[Musik]
in Südafrika ist die Schere zwischen Arm
und Reich am größten die Folgen dieser
Ungleichheit der Gesellschaft sind
deutlich sichtbar und sehr real
Unternehmen versuchen die soziale
Gerechtigkeit wiederherzustellen und
somit die Wirtschaft zu retten
Ungleichheit ist eine der entscheidenden
Herausforderungen unserer Zeit in
Südafrika zeigen sich die Folgen in
anhaltender Armut und in Angst vor
Kriminalität die die wohlhabenderen
Vororte in weiten Teilen des Landes
prägt
betrachten man das große Ganze und somit
das Wohlergehen eines Landes sieht man
das auf lange Sicht diese dramatische
Verteilung von Wohlstand und
Ungleichheit sehr ungesund ist
es wird kein Erfolgsmodell sein in einer
Welt zu leben in der die Reichen und
Single von hohen Mauern isoliert sind
während die Armen vor den Toren sitzen
und um Essen betteln
in Südafrika gibt es mehr private
Sicherheitsleute als Polizisten sie
patroullieren in den gelbe des Landes
und sind das sichtbarste Beispiel für
eine ungleiche Gesellschaft
die Kriminalität ist präsent in Haus im
Garten im Grunde überall
das soll nicht furchterregend klingen
wir leben damit und wir haben hier ein
gutes Leben aber es ist immer
schwieriger geworden die eigene Familie
und das eigene Zuhause zu schützen
darauf konzentrieren wir uns
CSS tactical ist ein privates
Sicherheitsunternehmen in Johannesburg
das insgesamt 750 Mitarbeiter
beschäftigt
unser Konzept umfasst mehrere
Sicherheitsaspekte ob bewaffnete
Bereitschaft oder proaktive Patrouille
das Fahrzeug steht also nicht einfach
nur unter einem Baum und wartet auf
Anweisungen sie sind rund um die Uhr
präsent und patroullieren die Straßen
Auf und Ab intelligente Software erkennt
ungewöhnliches Verhalten und alarmiert
uns jemanden um 5 Uhr nachmittags auf
dem Heimweg zu sehen ist normal aber
jemanden zu sehen der um 3 Uhr morgens
auf und abläuft ist ungewöhnlich es wird
aktiv beobachtet und nicht einfach
darauf gewartet dass der Alarm losgeht
die Angst vor Kriminalität spaltet
Johannesburg im vergangenen Jahr gab es
allein hier über 21.000 Einbrüche
johannesburg ist die Finanzmetropole
daher gibt es hier eine größere
Konzentration von Wohlstand und
wohlhabenden Menschen es gibt hier eine
Menge Dinge die man sehen und stehlen
kann die Schere zwischen Arm und Reich
ist groß und Arbeitslosigkeit ist weit
verbreitet ich glaube die Menschen
vergessen immer dass man mit
Kriminalität seinen Lebensunterhalt
verdienen kann
Südafrika ist heute ungleicher als zu
Zeiten der Apartheid aber Unternehmen im
ganzen Land bemühen sich aktiv darum
dieses Problem anzugehen und soziale
Gerechtigkeit zu fördern
ich war mit meiner ersten Tochter
schwanger wir lebten auf eine Farm also
war ich tagsüber zu Hause und unterhielt
mich mit den Frauen die auf den Feldern
nebenan arbeiteten sie pflückten Salat
und hatten diesen Ausdruck in ihren
Augen als hätten sie keine Möglichkeit
irgendwo anders hinzugehen
keine Möglichkeit sich weiterzubilden
oder weiterzukommen da wurde mir klar
dass es einfach nichts gibt und diese
Möglichkeiten zu schaffen
Aaron hat zusammen mit ihrer Schwester
mave das mangoanami gegründet ein
Wellnesscenter für das sie überwiegend
Personal aus den ländlichen Gebieten
rekrutieren
da waren nur diese Frauen vom Feld
nebenan also gingen sie nach Hause und
holten ihre Schwestern und Tanten die
arbeitslos waren und wir bildeten sie
aus ich erkannte sehr schnell welche
Chance das für Sie und für Südafrika
darstellte für viele ist es die einzige
Chance auf ein besseres Leben
[Musik]
war eine der ersten Frauen die Aaron und
maef eingestellt haben aber ist ich weiß
noch genau ich war auf dem Weg in die
Kirche da traf ich mich sie nahm mich
mit dem Auto mit und wir kamen ins
Gespräch sie fragte was sich derzeit
mache ob ich Arbeit habe ich ging
derzeit noch zur Schule und arbeitete
nebenbei auf einer Hühnerfarm wo man
etwa 20 Rand pro Tag verdiente
dann fragte sie warum kommst du nicht zu
uns nachdem ich eine Woche lang überlegt
hatte sagte ich zu ich hatte nichts zu
verlieren also habe ich die Ausbildung
gemacht und von da an als Therapeutin
ins war gerettet ich habe ganz unten mit
Massagen angefangen es hat mir wirklich
Spaß gemacht und nach drei Monaten wurde
ich dann eine der Managerinnen
innerhalb eines Jahres wurde ich dann
zum General Manager befördert was für
mich ein Riesenschritt in so kurzer Zeit
war
das Mango Nani hat sich zu einem
erfolgreichen Programm zur Schaffung von
Arbeitsplätzen entwickelt es hat das
Potenzial Frauen wie Christine aus der
ländlichen Armut in führende Positionen
zu befördern
wir haben etwa 20.000 Leute ausgebildet
Frauen die seit acht oder neun Jahren
bei uns sind und es bis nach ganz oben
geschafft haben und nun Managerinnen
sind ich bin stolz dass unsere Filialen
von Frauen geleitet werden die sich
hochgearbeitet haben
Aaron geht sogar noch einen Schritt
weiter und führt ein neues
Geschäftsmodell ein um ihren
Mitarbeitenden Anteile am Unternehmen zu
geben im Moment gehören unseren
MitarbeiterInnen ungefähr 30% des
Unternehmens ich wollte unbedingt dass
sie Teil des Unternehmens sind denn wenn
man so viele Behandlungen durchführt
gibt man so viel von sich selbst
indem sie ausbildet
Aufstiegsmöglichkeiten aufzeigt und
sogar eine Beteiligung an Ihrem
Unternehmen bietet hofft sie dass ihre
Firma dazu beitragen kann die
Ungleichheit in Südafrika zu beenden
ich kann mich um meine Kinder und um
meine Familie kümmern wir als schwarze
Gemeinschaften haben so viele Familien
für die wir sorgen ich bin der Ernährer
zu Hause ich trage viel Verantwortung
auch für die Jobs der anderen mein Job
ist wichtig für mich und für alle
anderen die hier arbeiten
hat unser Leben besser gemacht es gibt
uns Hoffnung und erinnert uns daran dass
Träume wahr werden können
Ungleichheit ist zu einem Symbol der
südafrikanischen Wirtschaft geworden
doch wenn mehr getan wird um soziale
Gerechtigkeit zu schaffen wird dies
nicht mehr lange der Fall sein
[Musik]
wenn Haushalte in bitterer Armut leben
können sie nicht viel zum
wirtschaftlichen Wohlstand beitragen
wenn einkommensschwache
Bevölkerungsgruppen in die
Arbeiterklasse oder Mittelschicht
aufsteigen sind sie in der Regel besser
ausgebildet es gibt weniger Kriminalität
eine stärkere Familienstruktur und sie
sind in der Regel viel produktiver in
der Wirtschaft
sie konsumieren und investieren auch
viel mehr eine starke Mittelschicht eine
starke Arbeiterklasse ist somit das
Rückgrat einer gesunden Demokratie
was die Zukunft angeht bin ich
vorsichtig auf die Messe ich glaube dass
der Weg zu einer Welt des
Wirtschaftswachstums der sozialen
Mobilität und der Verbesserung der
Statistiken zur Einkommensungleichheit
möglich ist das wird aber nicht gehen
ohne harte Entscheidungen zu treffen sei
ist die Steigerung des
Wirtschaftswachstums oder die Steigerung
der sozialen Mobilität wir müssen
sicherstellen dass wir uns mit diesen
Faktoren auseinandersetzen um eine
Situation zu vermeiden in der die
Gesellschaft völlig unzufrieden ist
[Musik]
vor so viel die fossilen Brennstoffe
haben unsere Welt geformt Kohle und Öl
aus den Tiefen unserer Erde sind nicht
nur in riesigen Mengen vorhanden sie
sind auch leicht zu transportieren und
zu lagern
ohne fossile Brennstoffe wird es keine
industrielle Revolution geben ein großer
Teil unserer Landwirtschaft wäre
unmöglich und wir hätten wahrscheinlich
große Schwierigkeiten unsere heutige
Bevölkerung zu ernähren ganz zu
schweigen von Smartphones Strom und so
weiter es wäre schwierig gewesen eine
Zivilisation ohne fossile Brennstoffe
aufzubauen
jeden Tag werden weltweit fast 100
Millionen Fässer Öl verbraucht im Jahr
2014 entfielen 85% des weltweiten
Energieverbrauchs auf fossile
Brennstoffe doch die Regierungen sind
besorgt über den Klimawandel und die
Umweltverschmutzung
wir sehen es in den Städten wie Shanghai
und sogar in New York Paris und London
die Luftverschmutzung wird ein immer
wichtigeres politisches Thema und dann
ist da natürlich noch der Klimawandel
die politischen Entscheidungsträger auf
der ganzen Welt erkennen zunehmend dass
sie handeln müssen
fossile Brennstoffe stellen für den
Westen eine politische Herausforderung
dar die größten Ölvorkommen befinden
sich in Regionen die oft politisch
instabil oder gespalten sind
neben politischer sorgen müssen sich
auch Verbraucher umstellen
[Musik]
in der Vergangenheit wurde das
Energiesystem durch große Investitionen
große Energieunternehmen angetrieben die
von der Regierung unterstützt wurden
doch zunehmend haben die Verbraucher
mehr Wahlmöglichkeiten so dass Sie Ihre
eigenen energieentscheidungen treffen
können sie können sich zum Beispiel für
eine Solaranlage auf ihren Dach
entscheiden oder in andere
energiespeichermöglichkeiten investieren
sie könnten ein Elektrofahrzeug kaufen
bis vor kurzem waren Verbraucher Erträge
sie interessierten sich nicht dafür wie
Energie gewonnen wird oder wie viel sie
verbrauchten das ändert sich jetzt
die Abkehr von fossilen Brennstoffen aus
unserem Energiemix ist jedoch eine
gewaltige Aufgabe die für unsere
Volkswirtschaften große Gefahren birgt
wenn wir von heute auf morgen von
fossilen Brennstoffen auf erneuerbare
Energien umsteigen würden gäbe es das
reinste Chaos denn wir haben noch nicht
herausgefunden wie das gehen soll
aber die Kosten für Energie ändern sich
die finanziellen Schocks zu Beginn des
21 jahrhunderts haben die Ökonomie des
Energiemarktes möglicherweise
verunsichert
die Finanzkrise hatte zwei große
Auswirkungen zum einen hat sie über 190
Milliarden US-Dollar an Fördermitteln
für die grüne Wirtschaft generiert die
Industrieproduktion und die Nachfrage
nach Strom und Energie ging zurück die
Haushalte wurden sparsamer und achten
nunmehr auf ihren Energieverbrauch
viele fingen an darüber nachzudenken wie
sie ihre Rechnungen senken könnten
kombiniert man das mit erneuerbaren
Energien so sieht man die Anfänge des
Umbruchs den wir derzeit erleben
die Ergebnisse dieses Umbruchs sind
überall auf der Welt zu sehen
Griechenland erzeugte 2014 9,5% seines
Stroms aus seinen Energie Italien 8,7
und Deutschland 6,3 Prozent das sind
keine riesigen zahlen aber sie zeigen
dass man eine reale Wirtschaft haben
kann die im Wesentlichen von
intermittierenden erneuerbaren Energien
lebt ohne dass es in einer Katastrophe
endet
die Solarenergie selbst ist in den
letzten fünf Jahren um etwa 75% billiger
geworden der Preis für Windenergie ist
im Schnitt um etwa 25% gefallen diese
beiden Technologien konkurrieren jetzt
also direkt mit den traditionelleren
konventionellen Stromquellen
die Frage ist nun wie man ein System mit
variabler und intermittierender
Versorgung und eine zunehmend
unbeständigen Nachfrage auf der
technischen Seite integrieren und das
ganze nachhaltiger gestalten kann
Schriftsteller Wissenschaftler und
Investor in erneuerbare Energien er
glaubt nicht nur dass wir zu 100%
erneuerbare Energien nutzen werden
sondern auch dass wir uns bereits mitten
in einer Energiewende befinden die bis
2030 das Ende der fossilen
Energiewirtschaft einleuchten wird
dieser Umbruch wird unser aller Leben
verändern der Grund dafür ist nicht die
Umweltverschmutzung oder die Politik
sondern der Preis
es wird bald in jedermanns
wirtschaftlichen Interesse sein sich
selbst Sonnenkollektoren Batterien und
Elektrofahrzeuge zu beschaffen
das ist ganz klar eine Frage der
Wirtschaftlichkeit es wird zu
technologischen Umwälzungen kommen das
ist reine Ökonomie
Sieber machte seinen Abschluss an das
Stanford University seitdem investiert
er in erneuerbare Energien und
beschäftigt sich mit dem Aufstieg und
Fall von Technologien die die Welt
verändern können er ist der Meinung dass
wir derzeit eine der bedeutendsten
technologischen Veränderungen unserer
Gegenwart erleben er sagt dass bereits
2030 der Wandel zu sauberer Energie in
vielen Teilen der Welt vollzogen sein
wird
[Musik]
es gibt im Wesentlichen vier
Technologien die den gesamten Energie-
und Transportsektor verändern werden
Batterien Solarenergie Elektrofahrzeuge
und autonome Autos
all diese Technologien bedeuten allein
genommen bereits Innovation doch
kombiniert man sie miteinander werden
sie den Energiesektor revolutionieren
sie wirken exponentiell disruptiv und
werden die derzeitigen Energie-
Menschen haben Angst vor Veränderungen
aber Toni Sieber glaubt dass sie das
nicht sollten
dieser disruptive Wandel hinzu
erneuerbaren Energien wird sowohl
Wohlstand Kosten als auch neuen
erschaffen
das Internet zum Beispiel hat einen
Großteil der alten Verlagslandschaft
zerstört aber hat auch big
Tech-Unternehmen mit einem geschätzten
Marktwert von 2,4 Millionen Dollar
geschaffen
da liegt der neue Reichtum
Tony investiert seit langem in
Solarenergie designermeinung nach
führend in der Energiebranche sein wird
obwohl sie heute kaum ein Prozent der
weltweiten Energie ausmacht doch ihr
Wachstum ist rasant und die Kosten
sinken ständig
die Verbreitung von Solarenergie hat
sich seit 1990 alle zwei Jahre
verdoppelt in Australien nutzen rund
eineinhalb Millionen Haushalte
Solarenergie das sind 25% der
Bevölkerung
Solarenergie auf australischen
Hausdächern ist ohne Subventionen
billiger als die Kosten zu
Instandhaltung und Lieferung von Strom
durch das staatliche Netz
überlegen Sie einmal was das für das
bestehende Geschäftsmodell der zentralen
Stromerzeugung bedeutet selbst wenn sie
in ihrem Atom oder Kohlekraftwerk oder
was auch immer eine Null erzeugen können
können Sie wenn Sie die Kosten für die
Übertragung hinzurechnen immer noch
nicht mit der Solarenergie konkurrieren
erneuerbare Energien hatten in der
Vergangenheit mit dem Problem der
Speicherung zu kämpfen also der
Fähigkeit genügend Energie in Reserve zu
halten wenn die Sonne nicht scheint oder
der Wind nicht weht aber auch hier
ändern sich die wirtschaftlichen
Bedingungen
in Form von Lithium-Ionen Batterien ist
im Moment am vielversprechendsten
Lithium-Ionen Batterien haben sich bei
der Dollar pro Kilowattstunde um etwa
16% pro Jahr verbessert
wenn man also diese 16 Prozent bei der
Kostenkurve beibehält wird der
durchschnittliche amerikanische Haushalt
der Pro-Kopf mehr Strom verbraucht als
jeder andere auf der Erde bis 2020 in
der Lage sein Strom für einen Dollar pro
Tag zu speichern
[Musik]
in Australien wird es bereits jetzt
finanziell rentabel einige Stunden Strom
zu speichern in vier bis fünf Jahren
wird dies im Grunde für den Preis eines
milchcafés möglich sein für den Preis
eines Milchkaffees kann man jeden Tag
mehrere Stunden Sonne speichern
Solarenergie ist jetzt schon billiger
als jede andere Energieform sogar ohne
Subventionen wir sind also kurz davor
den Wendepunkt zu erreichen
bei dieser Art von Technologie ist es ja
so dass sich die Rentabilität
beschleunigt sobald die Nachfrage an
günstiger Energie dramatisch ansteigt
oder es zu Unterbrechungen kommt dann
ist die Solaranlage auf dem Dach die
Batterie in ihrem Haus in der Fabrik
oder in Ihrem Unternehmen oder Hotel
billiger als die Kosten für die
Übertragung
spätestens 2022 wird das an jeden Ort
der Erde realisierbar sein
das wird nicht nur unsere Art zu wohnen
verändern sondern auch die Art und Weise
wie wir uns fortbewegen
ist das Verkehrswesen erlebt derzeit
eine der größten Revolutionen seit ca
einem Jahrhundert das letzte Mal haben
wir einen solchen Umbruch erlebt als wir
von Pferden auf elektrische
Straßenbahnen und Autos mit
Verbrennungsmotor umgestiegen sind und
das war vor etwas mehr als 100 Jahren
in wesentlichen werden wir hier drei
große Veränderungen sehen die bereits
umgesetzt werden alle Fahrzeuge die
bisher mit einem Verbrennungsmotor
ausgestattet waren und mit fossilen
Brennstoffen betrieben wurden werden nun
mit Elektroantrieben ausgestattet
dass manuelle fahren wird komplett zum
autonomen fahren wechseln und der Besitz
eines eigenen Autos wird immer seltener
bis man im Grunde kein eigenes Auto mehr
besitzen muss
die Auswirkungen auf die
Automobilunternehmen sind enorm es
könnte das Ende der Automobilindustrie
wie wir sie kennen bedeuten
wenn vollständig autonome und elektrisch
betriebene Fahrzeuge gemeinsam genutzt
werden entstehen Dienstleistungen die
für den Einzelnen sogar günstiger werden
das Auto wird sie zu Hause abholen zur
Arbeit bringen zum Feierabend in die Bar
oder zum Supermarkt fahren und danach
wieder nach Hause bringen und all das
mit rund 90% weniger kosten
und die Auswirkungen gehen weit über den
Bau von Batterien und das Fahren von
Autos hinaus Toni glaubt dass sich die
Gestaltung unserer Städte das Obama
Gefüge unseres Lebens für immer
verändern könnte
genau
die Anzahl der Autos die wir tatsächlich
brauchen wird sinken denken Sie nur an
Städte wie Los Angeles wo 60% der
Landmasse aus Parkplätzen und Straßen
bestehen
in Zukunft werden also ungefähr 80% von
diesen Flächen überflüssig sein dies
wird uns also zum ersten Mal seit fast
einem Jahrhundert die Möglichkeit geben
unsere Städte neu zu gestalten
wir können nun eine urbane Landschaft
erschaffen die wir schon immer haben
wollten und auch benötigen
letztendlich läuft es auf eine
umfassende Revolution der Energienutzung
hinaus zwar wird Öl noch für die
Luftfahrt und die Herstellung von
Kunststoffen benötigt doch toni ist der
Meinung dass die Nachfrage nach fossilen
Brennstoffen die die Welt wie wir sie
kennen geschaffen haben bald
Vergangenheit sein wird
man kann die Geschichte des Erdöls mit
der des Salzes im Mittelalter
vergleichen 60% des Erdöls werden für
den Transport verwendet also wird der
Bedarf um 60% sinken und damit wegfallen
Kohle wird nicht länger benötigt und
wird ebenfalls als Energielieferant
verschwinden wir werden hier keinen
Bedarf mehr haben auch Erdgas
Düngemittel mal ausgenommen werden nicht
mehr gebraucht dieser Markt wird
vollständig in sich zusammenbrechen
es hat Jahrzehnte gedauert bis Öl die
Weltwirtschaft dominierte Toni glaubt
dass die Dominanz von erneuerbaren
Energien viel schneller eintreten wird
als wir von Biomasse zu Kohle und danach
zu Öl übergingen sind wir im Grunde
immer von einer Art der Gewinnung von
Energieressourcen zu einer anderen
übergegangen
diese Übergänge haben eigentlich immer
sehr lange gedauert manchmal 50 manchmal
100 Jahre technologische Übergänge
benötigen bei weitem nicht so viel Zeit
sie vollziehen sich in einigen wenigen
Jahren und können sogar innerhalb von
Monaten stattfinden und die Solarenergie
mit der Sonne als Energiequelle ist so
eine Technologie und sie ist kostenlos
wir müssen also nicht wieder von einer
Gewinnung zur anderen übergehen es
benötigt einzig und allein
Sonnenkollektoren mehr nicht das gleiche
gilt für Elektrofahrzeuge es ist eine
Technologie
die Technologie zu Erzeugung
erneuerbarer Energien ändert sich rapide
zum Beispiel die zur Herstellung
transparenter Solarzellen
wenn wir heute an Solaranlagen denken
denken wir eigentlich nur an Dächer aber
in nur wenigen Jahren werden wir in der
Lage sein unsere Fenster mit
Solarkollektoren auszustatten
stellen Sie sich diese riesigen
Geschäftsgebäude oder Hochhäuser mit
ihrer Vielzahl an Fenstern vor diese
würden als eine Art 3 Megawatt
Solarkraftwerk fungieren
wenn man mal von den Kosten für
Batterien Solarenergie Elektrofahrzeuge
und autonomen Fahrzeugen absieht werden
die Kosten für Energie-
die saubere Revolution die Toni
voraussagt hat enorme politische
Auswirkungen sie hat das Potenzial die
Wirtschaft ganzer Nationen zu verändern
und das macht Gleichgewicht der Welt zu
verschieben
die Auswirkungen für den Nahen Osten
werden gewaltig sein
wenn der Westen kein Öl mehr braucht
verliert er auch sein strategisches
Interesse und engagiert sich nicht mehr
so stark im Nahen Osten wie er es heute
tut
das wird ein Ende haben Länder oder
Staaten wie Kalifornien Korea oder
Deutschland also Länder welche die Green
energy-bewegung vorantreiben und hier
führend sind werden die führenden
Industrieländer des 21 jahrhunderts sein
[Musik]
in der News in der nordafrikanischen
Wüste hat ein Land sich dieser
strahlenden Zukunft verschrieben marokko
hat gerade das größte Solarkraftwerk der
Welt in Betrieb genommen schon bald wird
Energie aus der Sonne in die reichsten
Volkswirtschaften der Welt exportiert
werden und das Leben von Millionen von
Menschen verändern
Toni Sieber ist Wissenschaftler und
Investor im Bereich der erneuerbaren
Energien für ihn steht Solarenergie im
Mittelpunkt dieser Technologien in einer
Stunde fällt genug Sonnenlicht auf die
Erdoberfläche um den gesamten Planeten
ein Jahr lang mit Strom zu versorgen
aber die Technologie die benötigt wird
um die Energie einzufangen zu speichern
und zu exportieren war bisher
unausgereift bis jetzt
hier links sehen Sie das Kraftwerk nur
one ein Solarkraftwerk
wie Sie sehen können haben wir hier ein
riesiges Solarfeld mit
photovoltaik-spiegeln und einer
Gesamtfläche von etwa 480 Hektar
dies ist das sonnenwärmekraftwerk nur
eins in Marokko ungefähr 10 km
nordöstlich der Stadt wassersaat es ist
die erste von vier gigantischen Anlagen
die nach ihrer Fertigstellung zusammen
das größte Kraftwerk der Welt bilden
werden
wir haben insgesamt eine Spiegelfläche
von 1,4 Millionen Quadratmetern die in
Summe etwa 500.000 Spiegel umfasst
sie sind wegen der Höhenlage und des
wasserableitungssystems in sieben
Bereiche aufgeteilt diese Anlage kann
ungefähr 2 Millionen Menschen mit
Energie versorgen
das Projekt nutzt eine neue Technologie
um einen der größten Nachteile der
Solarenergie zu überwinden die
Unfähigkeit Energie zu liefern wenn die
Sonne nicht scheint
die vogel-achse in der Mitte der
brennachse befindet sich eine
Flüssigkeit die als
wärmeübertragungsflüssigkeit bezeichnet
wird die gesamte Strahlung die von den
Sonnenstrahlen ausgeht läuft in dieser
Flüssigkeit zusammen
wir können
sie sehen hier diese zwei riesigen Tanks
in diesen tankslagern rund 45.000 Tonnen
geschmolzene Salze die die Energie nach
einem Wärmeaustausch mit dem HTF für
etwa 3 Stunden speichern
falls wir also nach Sonnenuntergang
Strom produzieren müssen können wir mit
Hilfe dieser Salze einen erneuten
Austausch durch HTF und Wasser vornehmen
so sind wir in der Lage auch Nachtstrom
zu erzeugen
alle neuartigen Anlagen die wir
zukünftig bauen werden in der Lage sein
in der Nacht zwischen sieben und acht
Stunden zusätzlich zu produzieren
verspricht rund um die Uhr Solarstrom
dies bedeutet auch eine Umstellung der
marokkanischen Wirtschaft die 94% ihrer
Energie aus dem Ausland importiert
[Musik]
die Solarenergie könnte das Land von
einem Importeur zu einem
energieexporteur machen
hier ist der richtige Standort den die
Solarenergie wird in erster Linie dem
gesamten marokkanischen Königreich
zugute kommen
außerdem ist Sonnenenergie
umweltfreundlicher als Öl und das ist
nur der Anfang wir planen unsere Energie
nach Afrika und auch in andere Länder zu
exportieren
[Musik]
woanders in Afrika wird eine
bescheidenere aber nicht weniger
bedeutende Technologie entwickelt
Millionen ausgedienter Plastiktüten
Treiben in der südafrikanischen
Landschaft umher
ist ein Start-up das Pionierarbeit
leistet und dieses schmutzige Plastik in
saubere energieumwandelt
zunächst wird das Plastik von der
Mülldeponie in die Station transportiert
wir nennen sie die Waschstation in der
Waschstation wird das Plastik zuerst
gewaschen danach erhitzt und zu großen
plastikmatten gepresst danach werden sie
an der schneidestation
zurechtgeschnitten damit dann daraus
Schultaschen gefertigt werden können
diese Schultaschen sind mit einem
solarbetriebenen Ladegerät ausgestattet
sie laden sich tagsüber auf und Spenden
nachts Licht
das Solarpanel wird abgeschraubt und in
der Schultasche deponiert so kann das
Panel während das Kind zur Schule geht
mit Sonnenlicht aufgeladen werden
später kann es dann herausgenommen
wieder zurück auf das Glas geschraubt
und als Lampe genutzt werden
so wird es benutzt
damit sollen gleich drei Probleme gelöst
werden die Beseitigung des Plastikmülls
die Bereitstellung von Licht für Schüler
sowie die Bereitstellung von sicherem
Strom für Familien die oft Kerosin oder
andere gefährliche Brennstoffe für die
Beleuchtung ihrer Häuser verwenden
sie brauchen so keinen Strom nutzen der
bezahlt werden muss gerade armen Leuten
mit wenig Geld hilft es sehr wie sieht
er dort
in dieser Fabrik werden 500 Schultaschen
pro Monat hergestellt sie ist ein
Beispiel dafür wie sich die
Energieversorgung von den großen
Versorgungsunternehmen in die Hände von
Kleinunternehmen und Einzelpersonen
verlagert und von fossilen Brennstoffen
auf erneuerbare Energie umgestellt wird
stehen wir also 150 Jahre nach
Entstehung der Ölindustrie vor einer
neuen Ära
ich denke gegen den Sektor der
erneuerbaren Energien zu wetten bedeutet
gegen Modernisierung und gegen moderne
Technologie zu wetten sozusagen eine
Wette gegen die gesamte
Klimawissenschaft man muss also eine
Menge schlechter Wetten annehmen die
wenig vielversprechend sind
wir brauchen also keine weiteren
Durchbrüche bei Solar-Energie wir
brauchen auch keine Durchbrüche bei
autonomen Fahrzeugen oder bei den
Batterien wir müssen nur lernen die
bestehende Technologie richtig zu nutzen
und diese Technologien weiter verbessern
so wird der Übergang zu sauberer Energie
von ganz allein passieren ich denke sie
wird unvermeidbar sein und wird noch vor
2030 kommen
[Musik]